yeah we need to see that yeah we're live
out okay
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
this planning meeting my name is
lawrence walsh and i am the chair
of this committee councilor aiden
williams is the vice chair
we have an attendance this afternoon
senior planning officers together with
officers from legal
highways and democratic services and
members of council who make up this
planning committee
for everyone's information this meeting
is being live streamed
and recorded for subsequent broadcast
please can you mute your microphones to
minimize the background noise
if you wish to speak please notify me
through the chat facility
go to item one's attendances and i have
um apologies from council stenit
councillor win stanley
and councillor morgan uh councillor
holden is standing in as a substitute
members
this afternoon thank you councillor
holden i know council stennis had
problems with his internet
uh today he couldn't connect so he won't
he will not join us
and then i just like to read out for the
members of the public the councils that
are present it may not be
immediately obvious to the public and um
if i if i'm incorrect please uh advise
me so
just to name the councils that we've got
present this afternoon we've got
councillor holden
councillor minis councillor procter
councillor jerome councillor rigby
uh councillor williams councillor
hartley will be joining us in a few
minutes
he's um got an engagement but he will be
joining us
council accordingly councillor dr
barclay will be joining us as soon as
she can
and councillor walsh and um we've got
councillor uh shirley procter who is uh
speaking
to a particular application this
afternoon she's not a member of the
committee but she's speaking
to a particular application um
item number two is declarations of
interest
and just let me read that out to you
if i can
find it
okay members to give notice of any
personal or prejudicial interest
and the nature of that interest relating
to any item on the agenda
in accordance with the adopted code of
conduct so if any members have got any
interest to declare
you need to do that now um i don't think
we have
um item number three is the minutes uh
we
did move the minutes last week this is a
reconvened immediate minutes
where you can be in meetings so those
minutes were approved last week
uh answer number four is questions from
members of the public and there were no
questions received
last week so we've dealt with that issue
item number five
is the additional information report we
had a another one
sent to us on email this afternoon items
six and seven
were dealt with last week last thursday
at that meeting
item eight is applications to develop
and
a quick reminder to everyone as well as
our local knowledge
we look to the background papers listed
at the beginning of a generation
eight so the background paper is listed
at the beginning of a gender writer mate
as a basis for our decision-making this
afternoon
so the application we're gonna deal with
first today
is three two one more side road in
flixton
and that's on page one five four of your
agenda
and uh mr day is going to give us an
instruction to this item
it's today
thank you chairman um we're just going
to get the um
the slideshow
is that working can you see the
slideshow no we can't see anything
hold on i'm not sure why that is don't
just bear with me
try that again
is that working now
no um
okay i don't know why not
um no just better just but just bear
with me let me just
it's not even telling me how not to do
it now um
can't get that down
uh yes uh yes please david i am
not that it will be any better but i'll
give it a shot
i can't i can't even unshare now it
won't let me i don't know what is going
on here
ah okay right
right okay the the application has been
reported to the committee
um because there are six or more letters
of support
um received contrary to the officer
recommendation
of refusal in addition to this the
application has been called in
by councillor shirley proctor and
councillor thomas
the application relates to a two story
some detached dwelling house
located on the south side of moorside
road
trevor road runs along the eastern edge
of the plot it's surrounded by
residential
properties to the east south and west
with the golf course opposite to the
north due to the angle of the junction
of trevor road and moor side road the
plot increases in width to the south
the single story outrigger and lean 2
side extension are proposed to be
demolished a two-story side extension
is proposed um so you can see on this
plan the
the outline um the footprint of the
extension
um so the two-story extension would
project
beyond the rear elevation of the main
house and will be set back from the main
front elevation
uh front porch is also proposed
um so you can see on the rest of the
the slide show the the elevations uh of
the extension obviously
um set back from the main frontage
with the element projecting to the rear
of the main elevation there
um and then i think we've also got the
floor plans
yep so that that shows the relationship
to
um trevor road um
the position of the extension in
relation to the the side road trevor
road
and then i think there's also um some
photographs
um which again show the relationship
to the side road
the key issues well sorry eight letters
of support have been received the key
issues are the impact
on the original amenity of the street
scene and impact on residential amenity
the proposed side extension would be
cited between 1.1 meters
and 3.4 meters from the side boundary
with trevor road
and would project forward of the
building line on this road
officers consider that the pros
extension would result in a cramped and
over dominant
formal development that would be out of
keeping with the spacious character
of the street scene and the surrounding
area it's therefore considered that the
proposal would fail to comply
with policy l7 of the core strategy the
spd4 household guidelines
and guidance in the mppf and it's
recommended that the application is
accused
okay is that i've finished yet yeah
okay um we've got councillor shelley
procter and we've got mr rowe
um speaking to this item i don't know
who wants to go first
councillor procter would you like to go
first yeah
okay you have five minutes council of
procter thank you
thank you very much
i'm speaking in support of this
application
as from looking at it it's beautiful
it will go it will enhance the street
scene
not be of detriment to it
i'm speaking in support for myself
and on behalf of my ward colleague
councillor simon thomas
who also fully supports the application
and i want to address
each of the points raised by officers so
first of all
they've been eight letters of support
for this application as well as letters
from myself and simon
the planning officer told me that this
level of support was unheard of
in his experience there have been no
objections
these letters of support come from
amongst other people
the family living on the first house on
trevor road
next to the applicant's house from the
family on the other side of trevor road
facing the applicant's house they've
also
chatted two passes by who've said yes
this sounds like a great proposal
moving on officers points two to four
are positive and accept the proposed
extension has been designed to respect
the character of the existing property
and the surrounding area
it's also proportionate and is actually
30 smaller than an extension that was
approved on the neighboring
property 91 trevor road
next the house faces on more side road
the extension is significantly smaller
than other extensions previously
approved on this road
including two corner plot extensions one
of which is
full height full depth and half width of
the original house
and a total of 11 side extensions
between
139 more side road and my own home
on lindale avenue and mere 17 houses
away these 11 extensions include
two full height depth and half width
that are less than one meter from the
wall of the adjacent house
then the street scene on trevor road
isn't uniform there's no one main
building line
no single style of building and several
extensions fairly close to this house
the suggestion that this proposed
extension would appear unduly cramped
flies in the face of extensions that
have been previously improved
including a demolition rebuild of a home
less than 200 meters away
whose new footprint is 1.5 times the
size of the previous footprint
and is in one metre of the boundary
fence between
it and the house next door to it
then according to officers the scheme is
clearly in accordance with policy
l1 l4 and l7 of the local plan
and spd3 and sd spd4
the extension will retain the
spaciousness of trevor road as the
majority of the side effect
elevation is set more than two meters
off the boundary
due to the angled boundary the
spaciousness will actually increase to
3.4
meters 11 feet which is roughly the
the length of a hatchback car
an additional benefit the scheme brings
locally is it will provide local
employment for a builder
and their supply chain it will also
significantly improve the environmental
performance of this 1930s property
contributing positively to the council's
climate emergency
lastly it's a beautiful design
as i've said this will enhance
the street scene of more side road
making it
an even more attractive road to live on
because of the size of the plot it is no
detriment
to the houses on trevor road so please
approve this planning application
thank you
thank you councillor procter um do we
have mr rowe
uh yes sir mr rowe you have three
minutes thank you cool thank you
thank you chair good afternoon committee
my name is peter rowe and i'm the
applicant
while i'm an experienced chartered town
planner i address you today as a husband
and as a dad
i live at the property with my wife
vanessa we have a two-year-old daughter
emmeline and we're expecting number two
early next year
we really love ernst we hope to live
here for decades
there are fabulous green spaces a
thriving town centre
and an excellent school just a stone
froze from our front door
we wish to extend our property to
accommodate our growing family we do not
want or need much we simply need an ex
upstairs bedroom so our parents in
bristol and rest of the island can visit
us
after covered of course and support us
we have no family in the north of
england we rely heavily on visits
in normal times it's been a long year
with no support so we're looking forward
to it
i'd like to make three points about the
application firstly
at the outset of this project we met
with our each of our neighbours mark and
stacy next door kate and jake at the end
of the garden and d
on the other side of trevor road we
explained our proposals took on board
their comments
and we had their resounding support
following our first knockback we spoke
of our councillors and people who
regularly walked past our house and they
couldn't understand the objections and
they were happy to support us the level
of local support is substantial
this is a compelling material
consideration secondly i'd like to
address the relevance of spd4 the core
strategy in udp is the development plan
it has primacy
spd4 on the other hand is simply
guidance it's not a hard or fast rule or
policy
the mppf explains the level of detail
and degree of prescription in design
guys should be
tailored to success circumstances in
each place and should allow a degree of
variety
where it's justified the example given
in spd4
shows an open plan estate with a
perpendicular road layout
moore side road and trevor road isn't
like this and it has some unique
circumstances
the road and house layout is angled the
building lines do not align and some of
the properties associated cloak
sited close to the highway's edge the
thrust of spd4 is extensions must not
remove
openness the and acknowledge and we
acknowledge that our extension will be
closer to the pavement
but this is only a small pinch point the
majority of the side
elevation is in excess of two meters in
particular a large part of the extension
will be separated from the highway by
more than three meters or 11 feet
and as shirley said the equivalent of
the length of a hatchback car
there is no doubt that the street scene
will remain spacious after the extension
thirdly this scheme will deliver
benefits one hundred thousand pounds
worth of
investment to improve your property
securing local employment for a builder
and supporting the local supply chain
during this global pandemic upgrading
the dwellings environmental performance
retaining an aspirational and
economically active household in the
borough
and finally providing a much needed
four-bedroom family home
boosting local housing supply which is
presently dominated by free bed
properties
so in conclusion this is just about a
planning balance on one side you have
some very minor technical harm with one
part of sbd4
which isn't even part of the development
plan however on the other side you have
a modest extension that
is 30 smaller than next door neighbors
extension which was
granted under delegated powers an
extension that would not actually
actually lead to any harm
um to visual residential amenity and is
in accordance with the policy l1
an extension that is totally supported
by the local community and ward
councillors
and a scheme that will deliver array of
added benefits that clearly outweigh
the technical harm we believe we have a
compelling case and we respectfully
request that you support our planning
applications in what are unique
circumstances
as an aside if you are minded to approve
we would be happy to have planning cons
conditions to look at boundary
treatments perhaps we could in
introduce a greater amount of greenery
um and i'd be happy to move our shed if
that's
would increase openness on that
elevation and equally if you can't make
a decision today please visit us and
see for yourself thank you chair and
thank you committee
thank you mr roll um councillor minis
you'd like to speak to this
council minis yes thank you chair um i
was having a look at this and uh
lots of it reminds me of my own house
actually so um i'm on a corner plot
and uh you have building lines going
down the side
of our house and we had a side extension
we had to go for a stagger
in the end because it was the only way
to to um
sort of try and fit in some rules and
there are parts of it that go past
the building line and it was a matter of
balance and luckily it was approved
now um i saw i understand entirely the
the issues that
that come with uh corner properties and
trying to have an extension
i also understand the entirety of having
family so far
away and i can't see and
to me this applicant has done exactly
what i
i love to hear where they've gone and
spoken to their neighbors they've
gone and actually got support from their
neighbours and
um i can't do i can't really say no
to be honest i'll be supporting this
application so i'll be supporting um
granting and i propose actually that we
grant um
the permission to build this extension
thank you thank you council of minutes
it is nice to have um an application
when the neighbors are all
in agreement isn't it it's unusual
and that's down to the work of mr roll
um councillor williams you'd like to
comment
thank you chad um i i won't speak a
great length to this um
i think a lot of my thinking is in line
with the sentiments that have just been
expressed by council a minute
um reading the report when you see that
there's no objections that
the planning department itself
themselves acknowledge that the
design is in keeping with uh the
properties in the local area
and the design that we already see
haven't been brought forward
and developed and then when you see as
well um paragraph 19 which acknowledges
that there will be no impact on amenity
for
neighboring properties it does seem to
me that if it were um
such an unacceptable development and
in terms of scale that there would i
would have thought logically
been an impact on humanity so i i think
i find myself just agreeing with the
sentiments and expressed by mr rowan i
thank you
thank him for his representations this
evening and
when he said that this is really about
balance and to my mind at present
i i think the balance is one that would
see the application approved i mean
if members feel differently and wish to
try and convince me otherwise i'm more
than happy to listen and perhaps change
my mind but
at the moment i found myself minded to
approve the application thank you chad
thank you councillor williams councillor
procter yeah uh thank you chair
um obviously this is um just down the
road for me so i don't know the area
very
very well um and
like the previous speakers i think these
are really
really good plans and it's it's good to
see the applicant has actually
worked with the neighbors to adapt
things
and to and and talk to them to really to
talk about what they're trying to do so
i think that's a really positive side to
it that
you know that communication and that um
you know working with people
and being open and upfront about plans
um is really positive i mean if
as i say i know the area very well and
you look at similar
properties very close by and this
wouldn't be
any different to most others in fact
it's probably smaller than some
so i can't really see what the you know
the impact on
on on street scenes going to be um
and there's going to be no impact on
neighbors whatsoever and they're they're
very much in favor
i think it's quite telling that there's
been eight um
representations in favor of the
application which
i personally have never on point i've
never seen that many it shows you a bit
of a mix
so that is very very unusual and very
positive in this case
um so i think overall i
i'm going to be going against the
officer's recommendations
and supporting this um i think they're
really really good plans and it would be
a real shame if it didn't go ahead i
know we can't take into the personal
circumstances with the
applicant that said and we don't do that
but i think the officers made a
wrong decision in this case and i will
be
voting against the officer's
recommendation and i'd like to approve
it
thank you chair thank you councillor
council accordingly
are you on mute council accordingly
i can't hear your counselor accordingly
i'm sorry about that
[Music]
um
no should we come back to you concert
we'll come back to you see if we can uh
if we can get you back on
um counselor jerome would like to
comment
thanks joe um i do think um
obviously um l7 guidance is really
really important and
much of the requirements are there to
protect people but um
i did actually go and visit the site and
when you actually
see the house it is slightly angled it
it's not face onto the road
and and i i think this i think
uh the speaker mr rhodes spoke really
well and councillor proctor
about saying that this wouldn't be out
of place you know in terms of
other extensions in the area
and the way that it it's angled that
there is only a pinch point
where there's a short distance between
the the hedge and the extension
um so i i couldn't really see any any
problem with this at all
so i'll be supporting the application uh
too
so thanks thank you counselor jerome
councillor holden
let's come in
yes thank you sorry it took me a little
while to earn
i want to make it quite clear i am a
stand-in
for one of my colleagues on on this
committee
so my experience of planning committee
and planning matters
is perhaps much less than some of the
other members
however i have never
ever come across a situation where
neighbors
have supported an extension
in more than one and a half decades on
the council
my experience has been 100 we don't want
it
we don't like it the fact that
the neighbors here are in favor
is unique and i personally
would prefer normally to support the
the officers from their professional
position but in this case
i'm going to support the applicant and
suggest that we vote for this this
extension thanks sure thank you
councillor holden
um councillor rigby
yes thanks chairman thanks very much um
i really appreciate
the applicant who spoke very well he's
anxious to send his property
and i've really read the report and i
visited
on two occasions and i've listened to
the arguments
by councillors this evening
you know um i've also noted
that the residents are all together but
in their enthusiasm
you know which is great um they don't
refer
to the reasons why and planning
guidelines
those that i can see um
and these planning guidelines guidelines
which we must
um look at carefully otherwise what is
the point
um i accept that the proposed
development
is well designed but you know design is
subjective
um and i also accept
that it wouldn't result in an
unacceptable immunity impact on any of
the other properties
but the loss of amenity of neighbours
properties
is not even an issue in this report
um what is an issue is a very key issue
is contained very clearly in the
office's recommendation
and that is the proposed development by
region of its height
scale and massing design and proximity
to the side boundary
with trevor road would result in a
cramped and over dominant form
of development that would be out of
keeping with the spatial character of
the street seed and surrounding area
you know i've quoted from the officers
report because i can do no better
and i've not heard anything to negate
that
from from colleagues um
i i look like being out of step here but
having been
on this planning committee for many
years off and on
i'm very conscious of looking at our
planning guidelines
and our responsibilities and whilst i
fully accept the applicant's
desire um i'm going to
move refusal and support the officers
thank you thank you councillor rigby
um council accordingly are you able to
um
to join us again i am here but i missed
what counselor rigby said so i
i by default i come away
okay yeah so i'm not going to take part
in this vote because i've missed some of
the debates
okay that's fine um any other members
wishing to speak
no okay um councillor harvey's joined
because he joined us late so we
we won't be uh taking part in the bolton
this um
application um it's been i think
councillor proctor moved
that we grant this application going
against officer recommendations that got
a second
council a minute we'd like to second
that so it's been moved up we go against
yourself
you did it i think it was the other way
around but yes
all right sorry my apologies
councilman's move that we grant this
application
and council blocks the second it going
against officers recommendation
council rugby proposed that we refuse it
going along with that officer
recommendation
he didn't get a seconder so we'll go for
the
um granting if you like do we need to
talk about the reasons for granting
first miss cauley
we need both reasons for granting and
also
a set of planning conditions so members
are aware
what they what they would be voting for
or against okay i'm looking for
suggestions um
from the floor um reasons for granting
i don't think we believe there's going
to be a effect on it
anybody else um my
uh reason for granting was that i didn't
think it was a um
cause any visual immediacy problems to
neighbors
uh neighbouring properties and the part
where there is a pinch point where it's
close to
the um boundary to the road um
it's kind of such as the nature of
corner plots uh which i understand
having a corner plot myself
um that this is a sort of thing that
happens and you do land up with a pinch
point and then
the at the other end you land up with
actually more distance
and you know that is kind of the nature
of those sorts of properties so
um to me that wasn't um
a reason to say no and i could see the
immunity was fine i didn't see
it's not next to a neighboring property
that that where the pinch point is it's
it's a road rather than um and it's not
causing
a blind corner or anything going round
the road
so i couldn't see a reason not to if
that makes sense
yeah yeah anybody else
i think so summarize chad i think we're
we're saying basically we don't agree
with the officer's
decision that this impacts on the street
scene is the
number of it yeah um i mean the reason
just looking at the refusal um
by officers an overdominant form of
development we don't think it will be an
overdue dominant form of development
because the nature of the road
lends it there's a lot of space there
and um
so i i do not believe myself that that
it would be all overdone i think it'll
actually improve
the street scene um
and we don't think it would have a
detrimental uh impact on the character
and visual appearance of the streets and
i think i'm just fleshing out what uh
councillor proctor and councillor minis
said
um that's fine councillor i think we've
got
we've got sufficient there and on the
conditions miss coley that
there are standard conditions of
materials and whatever aren't they i
think
but there are the standard conditions
that we would impose in all cases would
be a time limit
um with which would be three years to to
begin the development we would impose a
planned condition requiring it to be
built in the course of the approved
plans and we would require materials to
match
the the dwelling stephen are there any
others that you would suggest in the
circumstances
no i think in this case um those
conditions are
adequate yeah okay those would be the
three conditions that we would
seek to impose them okay that's fine so
we'll go to the hard part now is me
taking the vote councillor holden
yep sorry counselor jerome i'm just
wondering
uh rebecca whether the um
mr did mention landscaping as well
and whether that could be included i
have just had that suggestion for mr
pearson as well so
yes i think that i think that would be
um
that was offered and i think that would
do a great deal to soften the impact of
the development so
we could impose a we could impose a
landscaping condition as well
yes i think that would be reasonable
yeah okay
i'm happy with that um
[Music]
okay um councillor holden how would you
like to vote
chair i dropped out for a few minutes
and you're okay what do you say i'm
going to absolutely
yeah okay
um against the officer recommendation to
refuse on for the uh
um to to to grant planning permission
thank you
that's fine um councillor proctor for or
against the officer recommendation
i'm against the officer recommendation
to refuse
you've counseled your own euphoria i'm
also against officer recommendation to
refuse
thank you councillor rigby how would you
like to vote for the recommendation
thank you councillor rugby councillor
stem it's not with us councillor
williams
to oppose officer recommendation chair
thank you
the council councillor hartley is not
take back this one
accordingly how would you like to vote
um i'm abstaining because i missed part
of the debate
okay you're upstairs thank you council
dr bach he's not with us yet
thank your best and i'll be voting
against the officer's recommendation
to grant the application for that one
two
has five votes in favor of the
application
and i think that's carried yes
that's been carried so the application
has been granted thank you everybody for
your contribution
um just uh to be clear that was um
against the officer's recommendation
recommendation we should
now do the substantive motion to grant
with the conditions that we've just
discussed
okay yeah sorry about that all right
claire
i'm sure members love listen to my voice
uh i'm not gonna vote so are we um
before or against
granting the applications that is that
the way to put it clear or against the
application
no this would be to grant with the
subject to the the conditions that
you've discussed okay
okay let's let me let me let me try
again um counselor minis
are you happy to vote in favor of the
application in the conditions
uh outline yes i'll vote in favor of the
um the application
jerome how would you like to vote
thank you councillor rigby i can know
you're going to vote
thank you for this council williams how
would you like to vote
vote to grant on a permission chair
thank you
[Music]
um with the conditions outlined are we
happy with that
then our legal yes
yeah that's fine thank you declare um
okay that's because you've been granted
i'm gonna go on to the next item
page 144 that's one litchfield role in
david hume
and jay is going to give us an
introduction on this as well
mr gay
[Music]
thank you chairman um
i'm just wondering whether we can get
the the plans on the screen again
which applications sorry that's welcome
field page 143
councilmanist
i'm just trying but i'm having
difficulty doing it now just give me one
one last chance
let's not let me do it i'll um i'll come
out and have a go
log back in and have another go in case
you can't get them up
i will just try and do it just bear with
me i think we've been having some
difficulties with this today
is that working uh yeah yeah oh
fantastic all right
okay okay um
yes so this application um has been
called into
the committee by councillor dylan on the
grounds that it would be unreasonable
to withhold the granting of permission
because of the impact on the street
scene and the immunity of neighbors
um so the application relates to a
two-story family detached property with
a single-story flat reef extension to
its front side and rear
which you can see on on these plans
the application proposes
a first floor side extension
um to create an additional bedroom and
ensuite to the rear
the extension would sit above the
existing garage directly adjacent to the
boundary
with numbers 139 and 137
canterbury road to the south
um objections have been received from
four neighbouring
properties
so you can see on on the layout plan
the first floor side extensions sitting
above the
the flight reef extensions which extend
which which project further to the front
and
rear um
the main considerations are design and
impact on residential immunity and in
particular
the relationship of the extension to the
rear facing windows and rear gardens
of numbers one three six sorry 139 and
137
which you can see on the layout on the
location plan at the bottom of
that plan on the corner of canterbury
road
um officers consider that the proposed
extension would result in an overbearing
and visually intrusive form of
development
that would have an unacceptable impact
on the amenity of the occupiers of these
properties and would therefore fail to
comply with policy l7 of the core
strategy
and guidance in the mppf the application
is therefore recommended for refusal
i'm just trying to get the plans back
down again i'm having difficulties with
that so if you want to continue while i
attempt to do that
we've got a speaker in favor of this
application let's begin
application mr sears do we have mr sears
yeah yes hi can you hear me okay yes we
can mr sears
thank you guys you have three minutes
thank you thank you yes um good
afternoon yeah and
uh thanks for the opportunity to present
to the committee uh yet my name is mark
sears and the i'm the applicant
um the reason for the application is to
enhance my living space to support a
growing family of four
who in the property we currently have a
constraint with a small box bedroom for
a child aged 10 years
coupled with my desire to stay in the
area for good schooling options
and to support and to provide a space to
enable the ability to work remotely to
support a new
normal working regime my previous
application
was withdrawn and resubmitted based upon
neighbouring concerns
and has been significantly reduced to
hopefully support a satisfactory outcome
for the concerns that were raised the
design has been set back
the length has been significantly scaled
back and the width is under half the
width of the original house
and would appear as a proportionate
addition to the size of the existing
house
i'd like to draw your attention to
section 4.5 of my planning statement
that
hopefully illustrates this the case
officer report focused on one area of
concern only
namely um spd4 guideline
unfortunately within the case officer
report there was no mention of the
mitigation steps i've carried out
i'd like to refer you to section 4.23 of
my planning statement which refers to
the
rear window of 139 canterbury road
the ground floor window within this
within the rear of number 139
single-story side extension should be
considered to be the principal window
window of a habitable room and therefore
be given the greater degree of
protection that spd4 advises
the their extension has been constructed
at a slight angle to litchfield road
and as a result of this the window does
not directly face the proposed first
floor extension
and the view from this would be at an
angle a substantial open aspect would
remain
to the south west and the breadth of the
outlook from this window
will be such that the impact of the
proposed first floor extension
would not be significantly overbearing
or lead to any
undue loss of outlook again they've
illustrated that in
figure 6 within our planning statement
i'd like to refer to section 4.9 of the
planning statement um
in in relation to 139 canterbury road
sorry 137 the ground floor window
um due to the reduction in length of the
proposed extension
number 137's remaining original ground
floor window
would not directly face the proposal and
and the outlook from this window is
already compromised by a conservatory
as such no material harm would occur to
this opening
again there's some photographs that
hopefully demonstrate and illustrate
this
the conservatory is glazed and has an
outlook from all sides
finally the section 4.8 of the planning
statement gives a number of
examples of separation distances within
the spd
for guidelines within the the uh the
local area
um i've demonstrated 12 examples with um
three of the 12 i've actually got a
shorter distance than
than the distance i'm applying for
ranging from 8 meters to 12.
so in summary i've made every attempt
possible to appease all concerns
therefore i respect for the request
members to grant planning permission
thank you thank you mr sears
um any members wishing to speak
okay well if i'll just uh just just say
a few words
to begin with um oh counselor minis
you'd like to comment come to the minis
well thank you chair um i was just
trying to
working out quite how how far uh from
the boundaries i just got one question
and then um and
how far from the boundary would the
extension
be and um because there's concern here
from uh
neighbouring properties that um the
the gutters and the roofing would go
over the boundary
is is that true or can can someone
please um rebecca if you know the
answers
okay can you help with that um
yeah the extension is set on the
boundary
um the existing existing garage is on
the boundary and
the extension would um be flush with
that on
uh on the boundary with um
those properties at 137 and 139
canterbury road
it's worth noting though that the master
of encroachment is not a planning issue
so we couldn't refuse an application on
the basis that there was encroachment
although obviously there are other
reasons in this case why officers
do not think it should be supported
does that answer your question counselor
minis
yes thank you thank you let us answer it
thank you
okay um right i'll i'll just say a few
words i looked at this went
to been to look at this a couple of
times and um
when i first sort of um thought about it
was
my concern was the was the street scene
what would be
what did it the impact on on on
litchfield
um or even cancerbury road and i didn't
feel there was
an issue so i was quite relaxed um
about the application i i i thought um
i didn't have any concerns with it and
want to
start looking into a bit more detail
that distance between
the um the walls if you like of
one three seven and one three nine
bedroom walls
the the extension proposed
just fall quite short of our normal
guidelines
and then with it were being um
half a meter something like that i
wouldn't be so concerned
concerned about it but i think it's like
four or five meters
short of our normal guidelines am i
correct in saying that mr day
yeah i mean i suppose it obviously
depends on exactly where you take
the measurement from it's um the rear
elevations
of those houses are not parallel with
the rear boundaries
so the measurement does vary across
the the rear of those properties and
obviously there's also the question
whether you take it from
the main rear elevation of the
properties or the extensions that have
been carried out
but in either way it is significantly
under our guideline of 15 meters the
the extension the relationship to the
main
rear elevation of the property um i
think varies between
something like about 12.4 and 12.7
meters um
compared with the 15 meters and then
obviously when you measure it from the
extensions
um it's more like about nine and a half
meters from from those extensions yeah
i think that's the uh the number of the
issue here i think that's
what discussion needs to be about but
let's bring in councillor rigby
councillor rigby likes to comment
thank you very much chairman um i listen
to the um
applicant who spoke very well you know
i've visited
um lovely house well well maintained and
i could well understand
his reasons for wanting to extend um
the officers report comments carefully
um
on the street scene and i don't
have a problem there it's the
design appearance of the development
itself is considered to be acceptable
but the achilles heel here and you've
mentioned it yourself
um is the distance
and the effect it would have on 137 and
139
canterbury road um
and in all consciousness i can't put my
name to it
you know i i i think the officer's
report is right
i know the applicant won't um appreciate
me saying that
but you know looking at the guidelines
and why we're here
um i have to move refusal
thank you councillor rigby uh councillor
jerome you'd like to comment
yeah i also went to look at this um
property two chair
and um it is quite a
type property where it's situated
and i tend to agree with councillor
rigby that it would be overbearing um
i i think again the the applicant spoke
really well and
on this committee we don't we don't like
to stop people from having extensions
and and
you know extending their their home to
give them more room
but i'm afraid i i also have to agree
with the
um officers report and i think we do
need to take into account the views of
137 and 139 canterbury road um because
it it is quite a high
um and it will be overbearing and yeah
i also feel that i couldn't support this
application
thanks joe thank you councillor jerome
councillor howard
thank you chair yeah i mean i agree with
with
with what you what you said yourself
really chair it's it's
however you measure it it is below the
the recommended distances and it and
you know having having looked at it and
being to look at it it's it's a
it's a it's a problem with a corner plot
i mean similar to the last application
what i didn't vote on the last
application but i obviously
uh looked at it and the difference there
was that that was a corner plot but it
was much more spacious i
think and the you know the house was it
was an angle on the corner plot
this is a you know a tighter corner plot
if you like it's very
very similar to my own house to be
honest we're on a corner plot
very close to it to a house on the on
the road around the corner perpendicular
and
you know i have sympathy with with the
applicant because you know we'd probably
like to
uh we've got a single-story garage at
the side we probably would like to
extend in a similar way and create a bit
more space but i know that the
likelihood is that um
that wouldn't that wouldn't be
successful um so you know i think it's
partly a problem
problem with the plot but um you know
because it's well bloody
the recommended separation distances i
think um i think i would uh vote to
agree with the officer's recommendation
as well
thank you councillor hartley councillor
minis
thank you uh thank you chad um i've
complete i think that
it is the overbearing nature and i know
that um council dylan has put in her
a part um in in when she called it in
that it's not it's not a reason to uh
refuse it well it is a reason isn't it
to refuse if
it's um you know it's detrimental to
visual immunity
immunity to the neighbors um so
although i do i do see how the plot is
is an issue about the plot
like council hartley said it's about the
where the plot is situated and
the nature of this and i think it's a
it's a it's a shame but it's just the
way
these these things are and i think
really truly i can't really support
something that
is so uh different to the guidance that
we have and i'll be
um i'll be supporting the officer's
recommendation to refuse
thank you thank you councillor minis
anybody else wish to come in
okay so councillor rigby's proposed that
we go along with the officer's
recommendation and refuse this
application i think
councillor jerome you seconded it is it
is that okay
so we'll move to a vote um
councillor holden will you be taking
part in this this vote
i will when i can get it to unmute um i
would agree with the refusal yeah thank
you
councillor minis
yes i agree with the officer
recommendation to refuse thank you
councillor procter how would you like to
vote i agree with officers
recommendation reviews
thank you for jerome how would you like
to vote i also agree with the
officer recommendation to refuse thanks
joe thank you councillor rigby how would
you like to vote
thank you very much councillor williams
how would you like to vote
oh it's in line with officer
recommendation please jenna thank you
councillor hartley how would you like to
vote thank you chair vote to
um agree with us a recommendation to
reviews thank you
thank you council accordingly how would
you let go
um i agree with officer recommendation
to reviews
thank you dr barclay's not here yet
and i'll be voting in line with the
officer's recommendation to refuse that
is unanimous the application has been
refused thank you mr sears for your
comments and uh
we did what we did all look at this in
detail but
those distances are just a bit too short
for us we really need to be closer
to the guidelines thank you everybody
for your contributions
um okay the last item we're going to
discuss
this afternoon is at 26 grange thought
that's page
122 of your agenda
and mr day is going to give us an
introduction to this item
today
yeah thank you
yeah 26 grange thought road ernst um
this application has been reported to
the planning and development management
committee because the applicant
is a traffic council employee um the
application relates to a
two-story detached dwelling house which
is located on the northern side of
grange thought
road um is bounded by residential
properties on all sides as you can see
on that plan
um the property has an existing
single-story rear conservatory and a
two-story side
and rear extension the proposed rear
conservatory is to be demolished as you
can see the rear conservatory on the
left-hand side of the
rear elevation on that um on the
existing elevations there
um the application proposes a single
story
rear extension which would project four
meters from the existing rear elevations
so
you can see on the proposed elevation
drawings there
the the proposed single store extension
um it would measure 8.7 meters in width
would have a flat roof with a height of
3.15 meters
the extension would accommodate an
extended kitchen and living area
this furniture would not project to the
side of the existing property
it would not be visible in the street
scene um the key issues relate to design
and residential amenity
so you can see the photographs with
existing conservatory there
officers consider that the proposed
extension would be acceptable in terms
of design and visual immunity
so that that photograph on the top
left corner shows the relationship to
number
28 grange thought road which i suppose
is
probably the main the main issue because
it
the application um the projection is is
200 mil further than the guidelines
would normally
um propose in relation to that um
that neighboring property but for
reasons explained in the report
and and the fact that it's only 200
millimeters um
it's considered that the relationship to
that property would be acceptable there
wouldn't be any undue
overbearing or overshadowing impact so
the application
is considered to be accessible in terms
of design and resolution immunity
and recommended for approval
thank you mr day there's nobody speaking
to decide from either four against i'm
asking for members of committee to
comment
anybody wish to open the debate
now counselor jerome you've got a
question thanks chair
i suppose with this application it's
only come to the committee because um
there's a council employee involved um
so normally i i think i'd i'd be happy
to
agree with it but um in in in
spd4 the guidance does seem to be
that we don't allow flat roofs or
they're deemed
not to be appropriate design i just
wondered why
maybe that's not picked up in the report
um oh it's not picked up
i mean i suppose because it's a
single story extension at the rear of
the property um
we wouldn't we wouldn't normally refuse
um you know unless it was unless it was
a
property um within a conservation area
or in a
you know a particular um concern
we wouldn't normally refuse a single
story rear extension
on the basis of the flat roof
design i mean that's obviously got to be
looked at in
in terms of the overall design and how
that relates
to the existing property but in in terms
of this
property we um we consider that this
wouldn't um
harm the visual immunity of the area it
wouldn't be visible in the street scene
um and the design is subordinate to the
existing property
um and would be uh would not have a
detrimental impact on the character of
the area
i propose that we support this
application but
interesting to hear from others too
they've got thoughts absolutely thanks
councillor jerome
councillor williams
thank you sure um similarly to um
councillor jerome i note that the
application is actually only before
committee because the
applicant is a council employee and when
we receive these sort of um
applications i always make a point to
check that there haven't been uh sort of
contentious representations received
from neighbouring properties and i know
that there haven't been any
representations received to this
application which are finally assuring
i think um the applicant the the
proposed
uh extension is actually quite in
keeping with what a number of other
uh neighboring properties on the street
have done and i think actually in the
photographs that were contained um in mr
day's
introduction you can sort of see that in
the corner of one of them
so again i find that to be quite
reassuring i don't think there's
anything particularly controversial
about this application
as a consequence i'll be seconding
councillor jerome's
proposal thank you thank you councillor
williams councillor minis
um originally i was going to have a
similar question but when i put my
comment in to speak
then and uh council jerome actually
asked the question that i was going to
ask about the uh
the flat roof uh but um i i i don't see
if
you know this obviously it's coming
before us because the person works at
the council
um i don't see a reason i was happy with
that that the answer that we've got as
well so
i'm happy to to grant as well thank you
thank you um councillor rick b
that's chapman just to say that um you
you've mentioned it yourself
um it and others have it is an
application by
a council employee but it's important
that the public don't think we just
rubber stamp these through
you know and we don't you know we read
the report we
visit and um and the report is very
positive
and there's um it
but i just think it's it's worth saying
that we do not
rub a stamp through and they're treated
just the same
as any other application when they come
before committee
thank you councillor rigby council
accordingly
thanks chair the only thing that bothers
me is this 200 me
milliliters um 200 mil um
it's about nine inches and okay it's not
very much
but he's pinching nine inches out he's
pushing the limit
and that always bothers me because we
have limits
to draw a line and
it could equally be said why doesn't he
pull it in those nine inches
um that bothers me slightly
because i think in some ways it's
pushing us
it's pushing us it's taking liberties a
little bit
um i'm gonna vote for it but
i don't like giving these nine inches
here and there
i think they're they're
applicants get wise to that and i think
it
it's not right yeah just on that
term mr day can you can you just just
just talk to that issue counselor
calling
i know you talked about it before but it
it's the relationship with 28 grains
thought that's that's the number of it
isn't it
as you indicated what
what what i think what we're getting is
the effect that
that extra nine inches that's been
pinched as a council accordingly says
what effect will that have on on number
28 will it will it be significant
yeah i mean i i think we've we've
obviously heard in the
discussion about items earlier in the in
the agenda that we
we obviously need to interpret the
guidelines um
you know we need to look at the
particular site circumstances when we're
assessing
um applications against the guidelines
rather than just
mechanistically applying the guideline
in this case we've got to take into
account also that the
the house at number 28 is set a fair way
away from the boundary
so um in terms of impact on on windows
um it's not as though they've got a
window in very close proximity to the
boundary so that's
that's obviously been taken into account
in that assessment and and bearing that
in mind and the
and the fact that it's only 200
millimeters
it is not considered that that would
have a significant um
detrimental impact um
so that nine inches is is it the very
the back of the extension and it extends
nine inches
past our guideline but number 28
isn't facing if you like looking at that
extra nine inches um
through the daytime are they that's the
point you're getting that you have to
sort of turn your head to look to the
right to see it
and there's a separation distance
between the two properties if you like
across the boundaries
am i right in the same manner today
they do have they do have patio doors
facing
that but that the room where in which
those doors
are positioned uh also has uh
main windows in the back of the room um
so again we wouldn't
we wouldn't we wouldn't put much weight
on
um the impact on that window because
there's another outlook
to the room um but in terms of the
window in the rear elevation
yeah as i say it's set away from the
boundary so
you know we have to take all those count
those factors into account in terms of
the assessment of the impact um
you know maybe if they're if number 28
property was closest to the boundary it
might be more
borderline but yeah
okay um
miss coley like to come in let's make a
comment yeah i'd just like to say that
that obviously it's important for the
committee to scrutinize applications
um put in by council employees and of
course we want to do that properly but
neither should we be holding them to
higher standards than others
um if the application is acceptable on
its merits then the accept application
is acceptable on this on its merits
yeah we do we look at all uh
applications
individually don't we judge everyone by
it
on its merits okay it's been proposed
and seconded
the speakers sorry you want to come in
sorry
just just just briefly i mean
irrespective of the
the nine nine inches issue um
was in my ward and uh i don't see any
issue with this at all really it's not
not a problem
um i think there's no impact on the
street scene
um no no impact on neighboring
properties
um and i think the
the plans are good i think it's a good
indicator that there's been no
representations from any of the
the neighbors that's always a good a
good sign and there's not really
a problem um so i think
as i've commented i think the only
reason it's come to
committee is because the uh the
applicant is a is a member of staff of
trafford
so i'm happy to approve the plans thank
you chair
thank you councillor procter okay it's
been moved and seconded that we grant
this application
in line with officers recommendation i'm
going to go to the vote
councillor holden how would you like to
vote i vote to
uh accept the application queue
councillor minis how would you like to
vote
vote to um to uh in favor of um
officer approval sorry officer the
recommendation to approve
sorry thank you thank you minister
councillor procter how would you like to
vote
in favor of officer's recommendation to
grant thank you
jerome how would you like to vote
i'm also in favor of the recommendation
to grant thanks to
thank you councillor rigby how would you
like to vote
in favor of the officer's recommendation
thank you
um councillor williams how would you
like to vote
uh vote to grant permission in line with
officer recommendation thank you
thank you councillor hartley how would
you like to vote
i could share a vote to uh agree with
the officer recommendation to grant
thank you
thank you council accordingly how would
you like to vote uh
in fact in line with the officer
recommendation to grant
thank you and i'll be voting in line
with the officer's recommendation so
grant that's one two
nine votes in favor of granting that's
unanimous thank you everybody for your
contributions
um that has been granted are there any
other
issues we need to discuss miss coley and
your urgent business
not this evening thank you chairman no
no um i can happily drive it meeting to
a close thank you for your attendance
everybody